good evening
so good to see you all
[Applause]
in many ways this this book
or at least one way of this book was
started 83 years ago when stuart was
born
and in another way this book was started
40 years ago when they met when john
markov and stewart met at the hackers
conference and that started a friendship
where they
traded things back and forth
in silicon valley
for those 40 years and then obviously
more approximately
in the last five years john was able to
write down all that stuff
for us in this book tonight and give us
a short presentation on it tonight and
then we'll be talking about that but
john is a a formidable
journalist on technology and the stories
behind technology for all of his career
and i know all of us were so happy to
find that he was the one writing this
book about stewart
[Applause]
so i have the dubious task tonight of
introducing stuart to the one audience
in the world who completely does not
need to be introduced to stuart which is
kind of
um
but i did think it'd be fun to share
with you in just a few of my favorite
documents so this by far is my favorite
stewart as a young photographer in 1964
shares his portfolio with ansel adams
and i think that if i got this kind of
an endorsement from ansel adams i might
have become a photographer
but stewart was was pulled in a lot of
different directions and so that's not
the way it happened
outdoor life magazine published this in
1946 and stewart as a young boy took
this pledge shortly thereafter all these
years later he can still recite this
from memory and i think this is the
through line through stewart's life that
pulls all those disparate threads
together
stewart's parents arthur bob brand and
julia morley brand if you want to
understand where stewart's coming from
you need to think about higgins lake
which was where
a
group of closely interconnected families
summered together
the brands the morleys the burroughs and
the bernards
and those interwoven families spent each
summer in an encampment at higgins lake
and and stuart basically was able to
have what he calls as a free-range
childhood and i think that better shapes
him this is the family home in rockford
i think one of the first things stewart
told me is he thought he had an upper
class background and clearly the
families in michigan from saginaw were
upper class but in this case i think
it's much more nuanced to my eyes that
home was a solidly middle class home and
the family bought some property upstream
on the rock river and the plan was
to eventually build their own grand home
but that home was never built because
the priorities of the brand family were
education
i think this is my favorite picture this
is a phone booth in his dormitory at
stanford in 1957. down in the corner you
can see some resistors which is how you
got free phone calls this was a
community that was known as the phone
freak community which preceded the
hackers community and of course stewart
was there
on a photo assignment stewart's favorite
period in the in the military was his
time spent as a photographer here's a
meet and greet with john kennedy stewart
backpedaled furiously so kennedy didn't
shake his hand he was supposed to be
worth there talking to the wax the man
at the top of the photo is jean varda a
well-known collage artist in the bay
area
in the 50s and 60s key to the beat
community and you know stewart had
discovered the beat community as a
stanford student in 1960 when he came
back from the military he found his way
back to that community in part through
varda varda of course was a close friend
of henry miller he's the one who
introduced henry miller to big sur
i think the other person one of the
other people in the boat is a man by the
name of jack loffler who was a
came out of the beat community helped
stewart create a multimedia project
called american needs indians ultimately
settled in the southwest as an
environmental activist became a very
close friend of edward abby's and he's
actually the person who buried edward
abbey you can't always trust documents
and one of the things i've found is that
documents are essential but they're not
enough and one of the things that
stewart did after coming back from the
army one of the first things he did was
basically took part in this remarkable
experiment that took place over about
four years run by the international
foundation for vance study
and they believed that they could prove
that there was a connection between lsd
and creativity and stewart was one of
their first subjects he spent about 500
for this experiment and they took him
through a very intense experience
experience so this is from stewart's
journal two oral doses of lsd and then a
third dose
by injection can you imagine that um
now both stewart and jim faddeman who
was one of the people who helped him as
a guide to that said that that wasn't
accurate
third person don allen who was also
involved said that they used lsd by
injection to break down the very tough
subjects the tough nut to crack with
stewart in this case
they were trying to break his barriers
down apparently so i was never able to
get to the bottom of this but the
the documentation is there this is
stewart on assignment um he was a young
photographer
on the warm springs indian reservation
uh in oregon
he went up there and he came away with a
different view of the world he ran into
an indian culture that was very
different than his own and he took
things away that stayed with him through
the whole earth catalog into today
this is probably the moment that the new
games movement started early 60s again
stewart was working on that multimedia
project
america needs indians and he saw these
young kids in the sierras at a
california indian festival playing a
kind of game he didn't see in middle
class white culture
there were no gender boundaries there
were no winners no losers and it came to
fruition about a decade later
this is actually my my one of my
favorite photos of of all it sort of
sums up san francisco in the 50s and 60s
in one picture stewart's talking to ken
keezy who's in the blue jacket that's
the prankster bus further and neil
cassidy is leaning out of the bus and i
think the significant thing here is that
cassidy and and brand were bridges
between the
the beat culture of the 50s and the
hippie culture of the 60s in different
ways
stuart likes to think of himself as an
off the bus prankster and here he was
hanging onto the bus which i i enjoyed a
lot i think that's going to the acid
test graduation
bill english is sitting at the terminal
with the glasses and english was doug
engelbart's lead engineer chief chief of
engineering for the project that
engelbart did that was shown
just across the street here in december
of 1968 to sort of the thousand best
computer scientists in the world learned
about interactive computing
and english told me that he had invited
stuart in because of stewart's
experience with the american american
needs indians project he was looking for
someone who who knew about multimedia
and of course engelbart um pioneered the
mouse and hypertext and that technology
we use today
in terms of stuart brand scholarship i
think this was my best discovery reading
this reframe the way i look both at the
whole earth catalog and at silicon
valley in a really significant way
so
imagine in 1967
everybody else all of your friends are
heading off to land to start communes
august of 67 stuart shows up in menlo
park remember silicon valley wasn't
named until 1971 but in the second half
of the 60s all the forces that would
create the valley were alive and they
were happening everywhere so stuart
shows up and he says with the intent to
let my technology happen here in menlo
park
who had the sense
that silicon valley was going to happen
three years later and stewart ended up
at at ground zero what he was doing this
the project he was doing was an
educational technology fair which failed
the funny thing is about the the funding
proposal is remarkable if you read the
funding proposal it reads exactly like
the maker faire and matter of fact it
was supposed to happen at the san mateo
county fairgrounds it was just 40 years
early
but what i walked away from this journal
with is one how close he was to
inglebart for the year before
he actually um started was involved in
the demo and then started the catalog
and how influential engelbart was on
stuart during that year much more so
than i understand i understood if you if
you read the subtitle of the whole
catalog it's subtitled access to tools
and if you ask stewart where did that
come from he'd say well i'm just
channeling i was just channeling buck mr
fuller fuller of course said you know if
you want to change the world just give
someone a tool and teach them how to
learn it but at the same time he was
influenced by engelbart and of course
engelbart at that time was work at work
on creating the universal tool
and so what i i came away uh
realizing you know there are a number of
books have come out real uh recently uh
the zeitgeist on silicon valley has gone
very rapidly from silicon valley being
able to do no wrong to silicon valley
being able to do no right and two of the
books that appeared in 2017 basically go
back to stewart's biography looking for
silicon valley's original sin
and it just i when i finished this i it
just flipped my perception entirely
about the relationship between the
catalog and silicon valley um in in
brandian terms they basically
co-evolved and that
what's interesting to me about that is
the stuff that stuart ran into in the
late 60s on the mid peninsula
and fed into the catalog
basically influenced an entire
generation
of young americans while
silicon valley was forming it was the
first thing that came out of silicon
valley basically and so i had to
completely turn it on its head
sometimes the internet gets everything
wrong too that's another thing that
probably surprises you
this is stewart talking at
the first hackers conference in 1984
this is what the internet says he said
information wants to be free and matter
of fact they got the date wrong it was
in 1984 19 not the 1960s
and this of course is what stewart
actually said
information wants to be very expensive
and information wants to be free he was
describing a paradox which
you know in a sense channeling gregory
bateson and yet you know we only heard
the second half of what he said and it
of course led directly to the open
source software movement and also became
the rallying cry for the dot-com era and
led us into this regulatory or
non-regulatory morass that we're in
today so thank you sender
thank you john and uh we're just gonna
ask a couple questions up here and then
stuart uh is gonna join us
so i just wanna ask a little bit just
about the maybe uh your background and
your process and looking through
a lot of your work you mostly don't
really write so much profiles or
biography work and and so i'm wondering
what made you want to do a biography in
this case yeah so
once again it's uh so i've been
i grew up in palo alto i grew up in the
heart of um silicon valley i played in
the hewlett household as a child and
silicon valley i mean my first book what
the doormouth said
was actually an
anti-autobiography in the sense that i
left the valley in
67 and i returned in 77 and there was
this thing called silicon valley that
popped up in the in the inner interim
and um
i've always puzzled about why it
happened where it happened and when it
happened and that's been a question that
sort of
has
bugged me for a long time and of course
stewart was right in the middle of all
that and so um one of the things i
should say i was getting ready to leave
the times in 2016 and uh got a call from
kevin kelly said you know stuart was
thinking about writing an autobiography
but he's decided he doesn't want to it
you should write a biography
and um you know i i i'm about a decade
behind stuart in a lot of ways i've i've
i've followed him through you know many
of his adventures and so
it was not only a fascinating life but
it played on a lot of the issues that i
was interested in
i i realized it since you met him at
around the time of the hackers
conference right or i think the first
time yeah that's a funny thing that's
the first time i remember speaking with
stuart the first time i have a very
clear you know i showed up in the truck
store as as a college student but i have
very few memories of it um that was a it
was a a remarkable place i mean people
talk about places like um florence or
vienna
and
that place in that time was an
extraordinary the the community the
counter culture community which
surrounded the three computer labs was
an extraordinary place can you say a
little bit about what the truck store
was uh well you know so
the classic story is stewart was on this
airplane coming back from his father's
funeral he began to wonder what he could
do for his friends who were um going
back to the communes and so he sort of
hatched this notion of a truck that
would take information and tools out to
the communes and sell them to them
and he took two uh sort of uh
beta road trips during that summer of 68
and the first thing he realized is his
friends on the communists had no money
so that wasn't going to work and and so
he pivoted in a classic kind of silicon
valley
way and
found the idea of this catalog
and and so that i mean the truck store
then became the
the home base for the catalog it had all
kinds of interesting mostly books but it
had clothing and tools and all kinds of
stuff and it was
kind of a beacon for a while physical
instantiation yeah of the catalog
and i mean i think what's you kind of
the book really exemplifies this but
your your slideshow as well as it
stewart kind of has this like forrest
gump level of like showing up in all of
these places at the right that kennedy
shot looks like it's actually from the
forest
if you remember where they edited him
but this is
kind of the amazing ability of being um
at a place either in some cases 40 years
too early apparently with one idea but
in some cases just the right amount of
early to um to cause something to happen
and i was one wanted to comment on that
before we have stuart yeah and i i
puzzled over that i've asked stewart
about that and stuart's thought about
that and you know
i i think it's uh a way of looking at
the world is the only thing i can sort
of surmise is is how you could do it i
mean you know
being able to do something repeatedly
you know when you do it more in two or
three times you think there must be a
methodology here and i i i wasn't able
to define them at a time
methodology but it's happened too many
times to have been coincidence well this
is a perfect time to have steward after
we can ask ourselves
[Music]
you are once again in the right place at
the right time right
so
stewart i want to bring this question
back to you is it what what do you think
what do you attribute this kind of
mindset that's allowed you to be there
and then also you seem to kind of leave
before it commercializes or
or something like that so it's
it's both good luck and bad luck maybe
i'm not sure
something happened at exeter and
stanford that
we haven't quite talked about this which
uh it's in john's book
i was never dean's list
i was a b student all the way
and one of the things you learn if these
late
schools and universities is you are not
the sharpest tool in the shed
and
that's anyway what i was realizing
and so in the poker game of life i had a
not very good hand what do you do well
you can bluff or um
you can leave the game
and what i sort of any of the not only
would the fraternities not have me the
eating clubs wouldn't happen i was so
asocial
and so if that's the situation what do
you do
and i think what i
realized is
if i tried to compete i would always
lose
but when you invent
it's not competition yeah
yeah and so inventing became my mode and
it's just question of acquiring a lot of
skills to
that you can apply to starting things
and you go and discover other people are
starting things to either help them do
that
or
learn from them how to do it
and and then the people who start things
tend to find each other the ones who do
it well
and that was that was my
that was my gang uh lots of different
people at different times
but um
we hardly ever competed
i mean you know there was i never even
bought dope
there was so much floating around
[Laughter]
they were all selling dope i didn't get
in that game but i certainly took it
when they handed it to me
so a lot of stuff was free a lot of
stuff was cheap
the great thing about the hippies is
even the ones who didn't have to
pretended to be poor i was sort of one
of those i lived in a 20 dollar a month
apartment in north beach if you can
imagine that
these days
um
and
and
you point out a wonderful thing in the
book which i can recommend
um
from time to time i would write my
mother and
he's read all these letters
that i wrote my mother from camp on
and my god what's in there
but part of why i was doing it was
at the end of these very informative
family letters i would say oh by the way
do you think you could maybe send
a hundred dollars
whenever it's convenient
and she would do that
and so i was
just
sort of in a trickling way
subsidized
and and i'll rap on this
so it meant that i didn't have to get a
job
and the thing that brian you know says
to art students now routinely is
um you're going to go out of here
and you can't make money yet probably at
what you really want to do and you're
going to be tempted to get a job please
don't do that
because if you do that
and then you see something or somebody
or you have an idea or there's an
opportunity to go somewhere you won't be
able to act on it
and you need to be able to act on things
right away
and so don't have a job and thanks to my
mother and that little subsidy that came
along from time to time by request
i was able to not have a job
and
not have a career and this is i think
the floating upstream thing but i'd like
to know from you what
why you wanted to call the book floating
upstream
oh well
you're an iconoclast um you do go in
different directions that was that was
one of the things that struck me uh
right away i mean i i described stewart
as being wealthy in an as-needed way
it was wealthy enough not to get a day
job and i think that was that was
that really was what you if you got you
almost did get a day job i mean you were
coming to menlo park in 1967 to look for
a job in the business technology world
what would have happened if dick had
gotten you a job i would have been fired
i said it was fired by the army that's
true
this is all a good argument for
forgiving student debt i think
the brian eno principle
of this the um
i think and also i think it's
interesting this thing about the things
that were misattributed to stuart and
and these quotes that i've seen now many
times that stay hungry stay foolish is
now attributed to steve jobs because he
said it but he's quoting you or it's
quoting the catalog but he's the only
person who ever quoted it or took it
seriously i learned as we did a thing
together for
the library of congress and afterwards
the people who had shot the film and
said steve would love to have a copy of
the catalog says stay hungry stay
foolish would you sign it and i did that
and sent it off and then a couple years
later you give that amazing commencement
speech at stanford
and uh and i sort of wrote to him and
basically said steve you owe me the
launch
so i went down and had a lunch with him
and it was great but i should have asked
him what the hell stay hungry stay
foolish meant for him
because now everybody asked me and meant
so much to steve jobs what does it
actually mean
what it meant to him i have no idea what
do you think
that's an interesting question of what
it meant to steve but i i mean the way
you described it well you know a lot
better than me well so i know a lot
about the creation of that of that
speech i mean michael hawley who's no
longer with us actually helped steve
write that speech and i think a lot of
the
sort of the catalog stuff was actually
co-created by those two okay and so but
in terms of that's
not known by people before now and
michael hawley really deserves that
credit
yeah
well
so i mean
i mostly i was mostly interested what it
meant to you because that you described
the relationship between that that open
road that was sitting beneath it
and you know the stay hungry stay
foolish it was the idea of a hitchhiker
setting out on a road and they didn't
know where they were going and life was
just this open
open book in front of them and someone's
eyes must meet the sun
again don't get a job
don't
don't get a job
i can't tell you when i took well so
first of all there's this this bimodal
distribution of people people who knows
people who know stuart they're they're
the people who grew up in my generation
who read the catalog and then there are
people who saw steve jobs commencement
address and then there's this big empty
space in between it's really but i've
tried to count the number of people
who've watched that um that video and
it's in the tens of millions i'm not
sure i don't have a real number because
youtube screws everything up and i was
just saying boy if i made a star in
somebody's speech that's the one
so and i think one of the one of the
things i really loved i mean i've i've
now known stewart for 40 years i was
falling asleep under tables he was
having meetings at sausalito
trying to say help save the waterfront
when i was in
um
so
but i was so surprised by some of the
early stuff that you pulled out and as
you point out we we always have seen
stewart as the leader
in almost everything he was first to
everything but what i never knew was his
the relationship with his brother and
how that he actually followed his
brother to the army to vlogging right
and then as well as stanford um how did
you pull all that stuff out where does
that was those materials that came out
of our conversation stuart i was very i
mean it was it was strange because he
had two brothers um and he
he had an older brother and and you know
i also talked to mike his older brother
who he did follow and
it was the relationship was largely on
stewart's side mike was not aware as
aware of stewart as stewart was aware of
mike right and
mike was kind of surprised when i told
him actually how how much you followed
him um but but and i don't
completely know why
stewart skipped over his middle brother
because he would have been closer in age
but he really he he really sort of took
mike as his role model um i you know so
here's here's how serendipity comes into
the world one of the uh the really great
things that mike told me is why he ended
up at stanford which of course is why
stewart ended up
so unlike stuart mike was a football
store a star at exeter and he was a jock
and all of those things and i think he
played football at stanford too but oh
he started too he started to but the
reason he went to stanford is he was in
the hospital or he was sick at one point
he was reading this magazine and he saw
that stanford
had this football coach that lost all of
his games in the season and they kept
the coach they didn't fire the coach and
so mike said that's the place for me
which was a great attitude but because
they didn't fire their coach like any
place that would keep a coach they
didn't take the sport that seriously
well he wanted the scholarship at the
place that didn't take seriously
yeah that's really great
i think the
the some of the stuff that you've
you've brought up and even i think
surprised stuart with i'd i'd love for
you guys to say a little bit about some
of the things that maybe the way some of
these things have looped around i think
was one of the things that the whit the
save the whales
movement uh
story i think was an interesting one you
know stuart has had forays over time
into activism he sort of i mean one of
the interesting sort of dichotomies
between stuart and i is that he's got
this antipathy to the new left and i
grew up in the new left and so that was
an interesting thing that we needed a
red diaper i was a red diaper maybe
that's true
but we didn't have any red diapers in
illinois i'll tell you
so so i mean one of stewart's sort of
activist ventures was putting um
a a
a group together to kind of create a
woodstock a woodstock home in stockholm
at uh this first global environmental
conference he thought he could get three
or four hundred thousand people in a
woodstock kind of way and i think he got
what 800 or 900 if that yeah and
and stewart was you know he was in a
tough phase in his his life his marriage
was falling apart and um he got there
and
he was pretty much erect during the
whole thing and and basically didn't see
that that stockholm conference
um and the you know the the save the
whale stuff came out of the stuff that
he did and there was of that vehicle
that was dressed up as the whale that's
right became this iconic thing it was on
every newspaper page in a front page in
in the world and in fact the save the
whales treaty pretty much directly came
out of that and so he was involved in
that and he didn't see that at all
matter of fact that sort of turned you
away from activism at that point yeah
the untold story of the whale in
stockholm was they
the hog farm was a bunch of buses based
sort of on
on the pranksters further and they
dressed up a bus as a whale which is
not bad for scale it was more
rectangular than most whales
but they had a tail and stuff like that
and they had tapes that was the big deal
when
um
humpback whale songs were a big deal and
so they had this tape that was going to
play a humpback whale song as it paraded
through downtown stockholm
and as usual in prankster and some hog
farm things
there was a [ __ ] up and they couldn't
get the tape to work
so they had to persuade everybody
marching to sing like whales
which was better
and and you invented the first burning
man art car as well
well that was another place that stewart
showed up first i mean you were on the
playa wall in 1960
62 or 1663
blackrock desert is his was and forever
will be one of the great places on the
planet it's where you really feel it is
a planet yeah the curvature of the earth
story is yeah but actually that's
another great story i think you kind of
you found earlier evidence of the why
haven't we seen the the picture of the
whole earth than i think stuart may
remember stewart talked about this how
things would bubble for years and
perhaps decades and
in this particular case you know he
tells this story about going up on the
roof here in north beach and on a half a
tab of acid and sort of wondering about
why the earth was curved and coming down
and stairs and starting this project
but when i was reading through the
documents i could see
that um
a lot of those threads were in i mean i
think my guess was he stumbled across
this in one of lbj's inauguration is
where he was
quoting um
um carl sagan about this blue dot and
stuart i could see stewart had outlined
that he'd stumbled across this idea of
of being able to see the entire earth at
least two or three years before
you stumble across it again
well you know as a photographer to have
your most famous photograph be one that
was taken by other people
it's a little strange so you can imagine
how pleased i am that the covered
photograph on john's book is a
self-portrait that i actually took in
north beach at the very place where the
the roof with the lsd was i i think
you mentioned this a little bit in your
talk but i think it's worth kind of
talking about a little bit more is the
amount of source material that you have
is kind of
staggering and i mean and the amount of
interviews i know you did i mean can you
say how many interviews and and how many
and how you got to how do you access the
emails you did access and so it's yeah
this was sort of uh
biography was was a new research domain
for for me and stuart had been kind
enough to keep stuff and stanford had
curated it but
um going through it was
completely um
so i have a a 16 gigabyte file i
digitized everything dutifully and what
i found is a at a certain point string
search breaks down as a useful tool
and the other thing stuart talked about
his
his correspondence with his mother i
dutifully read all of stewart's letters
if i had read tried to read his mother's
letters i would still be reading because
his mother's handwriting was completely
illegible
a computer might be able to do it but i
couldn't do it to decipher one of his
his mother's letters would take a half
an hour right it was really quite
remarkable i don't know if you came
across this document i remember when
there was a document when uh
for the trips festival uh
anniversary that was a while ago where
there was a the budget document for that
that he he submitted saying that the
grateful dead were going to play
and had booked them yep and he had not
even talked to them and then they they
showed up because they were on the
poster it was my understanding on that
story i think that maybe you should tell
that story that's my memory of this well
lois tells that story but i don't think
that in in the movie but i don't think
that ever happened it might have
something like that might have happened
with not the truth festival but the
later one whatever it is
um whatever yeah whatever it is at san
francisco san francisco state and it was
uncertain whether keyse was going to be
able to show up or not
and i think i sort of indicated that
pranksters and so on that world was
going to be there yeah and i guess the
dead did play
on the second night okay
and then that's when i i exploded the
place with an atomic bomb yeah yeah on
friday night that that uh
was a guy get on the stage
um
and and turn on the soundtrack of uh the
newscasters saying that the launch has
happened
uh it's gonna hit all of them and then
you know countdown to how long
and people are kind of going well this
is kind of weird and
i'd wired the place with
with
hidden flashlights
and when he got to i'm afraid this is it
folks and
all these things went off there was a
great big kaboom sound and all the
lights in that part of campus went dark
kind of a [ __ ] you to the audience
the other remarkable thing about the the
trip i'm not going to do that here don't
worry yeah i mean bill graham was the
one who took the most away from the trip
specials in so many ways i mean the day
after the trips festival um they met at
a cafe across from the fillmore which
was not the fillmore and uh that day
graham leased the fillmore um and the
first poster the fillmore said you know
with the sights and sounds of the trips
festival and so both the you know the
san francisco music scene and also i
think tom wolf said that you know the
the the trips the trips festival um was
the first time the ten thousand hippies
in the bay area realized there were ten
thousand hippies and had this way of
creating a community and there was a
direct line to the haight ashbury yep i
think that's true which of course stuart
missed i mean stewart has been called
the prince of the hippies and i think
that's just ridiculous um you know you
were a bridge to the hippies but you
were gone by the time uh the summer of
love happened you were down in in menlo
park pretty much yeah yeah and actually
i think this is a a good point is often
people
associate stu with the hippies but
really he was in the beat movement
and then how would you describe it is
that well i was quote silent generation
which was an observation made at
stanford uh
by
of my students by our faculty
who the previous set of students said
edward gi bill folks
uh the people who come back from the
second world war
wanting to get an education they weren't
there to get drunk
having seen more of the world than most
of their teachers having been through
combat in many cases and they were
taking no [ __ ]
and so they would in classes for these
teachers
um
push back
and real discussions about real stuff
would occur
and the teachers who didn't hate it
loved it
and then we came along and we looked
like the most placid
uh
kind of pathetic quiet
uh people they'd seen because that was
the contrast
and uh so we were called the silent
generation we later fixed that
but it was before the boomers and
so i was teezy was a little older than
me i was a little older than most most
of the hippies if you want to sort of
bracket it
um
late 60s 68 catalog and so on would be
sort of early hippie
and when
steve jobs came along and was
being influenced by the whole earth
catalog that was sort of late hippie and
that sort of that that was the and both
of us went out and tried to make do with
communions in the countryside both of us
got insanely bored and came back to town
pretty quickly
uh which everyone did um but almost
everyone and but it was because
we did an important thing which was have
these swan fantasies
and uh
not get jobs go out and with not much
money play out our fantasies
and then have our noses rubbed and the
mess that it made
of you know there's no free love there's
no free money there's all these
gardening is hard domes leak all this
stuff you know drugs make you crazy and
so we
learn like a good dog that is a mess
don't do that do other cool stuff and
you know the hippies had been selling
dope to each other so a lot of us
knew how to be
businessmen because of that and
here's another important thing
long hairs were
picked up each other hitchhiking because
nobody else would
and if you're along here you were
basically
um part of the problem as far as america
was concerned
except for business people
for reasons i don't know one of the
hippies sort of ethics was to be honest
tell the damn truth and uh and don't
whisper
and
so
we were strangely honest we would pay
bills you know when we got them and
stuff like that
and business people realized that long
hair or not weird face paint or not to
fraction gratings on the forehead or not
we're actually good customers
good employees
and then uh soon enough with our own
inventions good business people
and that's who we became basically
and i think going through that hippie
process
one of the things about living cheap is
you get
very aware that you can you get very
aware of what you can do with a bit of
money
and the reason the
demise party where we put i put twenty
thousand dollars in cash on the
on the podium for people to hold in
their hands and talk about what
everybody should do with it
that was such a zoo
i mean
imagine doing it now with the younger
generation with uh
crypto money and
stripe money and all kinds of uh
hey here's twenty thousand dollars we
have to decide what to do with it and
everybody would just walk out it's not
an interesting amount of money
[Laughter]
but back then the hippies it was an
unimaginable amount of money they had no
sense of how to do group process the new
left was not good at that unfortunately
by and large
and hippies were terrible at it so you
know you would argue and not do anything
that's why the education fair didn't
happen
and so it was a zoo but it was an
interesting too but it had a
serendipitous effect too spell it out so
um
they they spent the entire night trying
to decide what to do with the money by
consensus and they failed they said
cost your brand five thousand dollars
make a really great party and twenty
thousand dollars to spoil it
so at the end of the night at some point
this guy who was an itinerant drafter
sister by the name of fred moore stood
up and he actually burned one of the two
dollar bills that he he had in his
pocket that was all he had in in to his
name
and when people gave up on figuring out
what to do with the money they gave the
money to the guy who burned the dollar
bill and so fred moore who didn't
believe in money ended up walking away
with the money and and the great irony
you know is fred was a bit of a hacker
and he was involved in these events that
happened monthly uh these potlucks at
the
at the portola institute at the people's
computer center and when they fell apart
um he was one of the two people with
gordon french who started the homebrew
computer club
it's a good transition to the next topic
which is
you can see why people paid attention to
them because the deal was there had to
be a vote of who was going to get the
money and do the idea that people liked
and
gordon had
he had burned the dollar bill and he
said it's not the money you know you
just burned half of his money uh it's
the people and then he started
collecting a list of names and phone
numbers
and people realized here is the one guy
who was had actually had a good concept
of the real event this was a bunch of
people who could work together
and uh that it was not the money
and and just you know access their phone
numbers
and so then what happened
well ultimately two dozen companies
including apple came out of that and
then you know it was sort of that
i out of the homebrew computer club yeah
exactly um and you know
apple was that canonical silicon valley
company where was there was steve
wozniak who just wanted to build a
computer to show to his friends at the
homebrew computer club and then there
was this guy steve jobs who saw there
was a market there and it was that match
that for a long time i think was the
kind of defining archetype of a silicon
valley company
did when they sold blue boxes was it
steve jobs who wanted to sell them and
and
no and actually it was wonderful
who wanted to call the pope it was
wozniak's mother um she was the one who
read that article and she sent it to her
son and so they said story in esquire
about phone yeah that's right the
mysteries of the little blue box and
they set off on a quest to find john
draper and about three weeks later
draper showed up in their dorm room and
taught them how to build these things
which they then sold door-to-door and
that was the original capital explain
why john draper was called captain
crunch oh well that would that um that
whistle in the cereal box was tuned to
the exact frequency that basically
unhooked a watsek center and lets you
get a long distance phone call
so
in your
cracker jacker or whatever it was is a
thing that gives you free calls anywhere
in the world
how wild was it yeah
and didn't didn't you find a document
recently that was that showed that or
stewart maybe found it that that you
were talking about phone freaking
yeah that was a picture of before i was
a photographer because i was so pleased
of having you know bought a bunch of
resistors across the street wherever it
was zach's facts no doubt yeah and uh
and just put them out for free by the
phone and what you did is you you took
the resistor put it in the base of the
handset and then found the
full piano hinge on the door touch to
that it was a ground because you had a
dial tone and call anyone
nice um and that's actually a good segue
and i want to make sure we bring this up
a little bit to you know the present and
and i think the um now
well not long now yeah but i think the i
think you know you're you're alternately
kind of blamed for all of the the wrongs
of silicon valley and
and kind of uh giving credit for some of
the birth of these ideas and especially
with the the well which is a story that
i think you get to and you were part of
and i think i'd love for you to tell a
little bit about what you thought of the
well as it started and and i'd love to
hear what stewart got out of that the
wellesley the ark of the well is an
interesting story and stewart's inner
you know his creation of the well and
his exit from the well was interesting
to me as well but you know i was one of
these technology writers at that point
when the well started i was just making
the the transition um from bite magazine
which is very technical to the san
francisco examiner thank you will um
and um
you know
stuart's brilliant marketing move in
starting the well was that he gave free
accounts to people like me and steven
levy and a bunch of other technology
rights and to hackers and hackers that's
right uh it created this community but
it also basically gave the well an
out-of-scale reputation i don't think
there were never more than 14 thousand
members of the well i'd be surprised
yeah if i had to situate you know there
was a digital culture that emerged but
the well was a pretty small part of it
it wasn't first i mean there was
i'm sorry the well
uh is still uh but you know there was um
there there was compuserve there was a
source there was prodigy and most
importantly i think if you wanted to
situate a digital culture there was
usenet um all of the unix uh all the
unix data centers around the country
were connected and there was a very kind
of libertarian spirit a hacker spirit in
those and that basically was happening
at the same time it was fidonet was
going on all of this stuff was happening
and the well was a big big part of it
but it wasn't
um and you know the other thing that i
took away i called that chapter
anonymity
because stewart had seen some of the
things that we're now recognizing now as
problems in this cyberspace metaphor
what do you want to call it and he tried
to design the well to to deal with them
and
i think ultimately six years later you
decided you hadn't solved that problem
and you walked away from it
what i'd seen is that um
i've learned about the stuff that we did
on the well from a system called eyes
e-i-e-s
i guess
and um
i was on a system with a limited
conversation of about 20 30 people
corporate people intellectuals
computer people
and
we would meet twice a year and then sort
of go through discussing various things
and then in a sense i was on the faculty
of this group
um and
one of the discussion points that came
up is
anonymity is important because some
people need to be able to get a message
out without it uh coming back to really
bite them uh because it's an important
truth and and uh you know power will
will find them and destroy them
so let's have a little anonymous uh sub
conversation within these various
conversations that we're having on eyes
and it was set up and within two days it
had gone completely sociopathic
and what happens is when you have
anonymity people can pretend to be other
people
and uh as this other person then do
something really
sort of insighty jokey and cruel
and then that gets the other people who
are also now realizing they're anonymous
to be equally cruel back
and uh it spirals into real viciousness
really fast
and so that was why i wanted to be sure
that that kind of anonymity was not
going to be available on the well but we
did allow people to change their names
and would wind up being easy for them to
get separate accounts and they'd be
kicked off the well and they come back
at somebody else and
uh we did not control it
and facebook originally it was your
facebook identity that was going to be
your digital identity in the world and
then that got lost for them and
you see the downstream so i think
still that
you own your own words you're
responsible for your own words
and
it's not only that you're responsible
for your own words on the line it's
actually a loyal you not a bot
not somebody else pretending to be you
it's actually you and it's the true
names thing that vernafinger wrote about
i think we're going to need to have that
or at least a channel where that is
always really a lot reliable yeah
yeah it's pretty much a microcosm of
exactly what we're living through now at
a macro scale
and so
i think it's interesting how early that
lesson was learned yet not really
not actually learned yeah
the the cyberpunk science fiction
writers laid this all out for us in the
1980s what did you get about what they
were writing yeah i think people used it
as a roadmap instead of a warning i
blame myself i mean i you know i fell
for john barlow's uh john perry barlow's
utopianism as much as anybody else did
you know this was going to be this
socrates abode that was going to be
separate from the real world well there
was a lot of people standing behind john
kind of rolling our eyes
he would spin that out
but i think and that's worth touching on
too i mean there's the time i mean even
the time as long i was getting started
in the mid 90s where you know there was
the techno optimism was a was very much
part of of the
your scene and the long now founding um
and then as as that optimism has has
certainly faded in some cases turned to
absolute terror
how do you how do you feel in your kind
of birth of this movement and then where
it's gone and and and and that
the
the pendulum of attention that goes from
everything is great about an actually
mixed bag
to everything is terrible about an
actually mixed bag
is
i don't know i guess one of the ways
that people catch on
learn that it actually is a mixed bag
because you have to oscillate
um but it's a mixed bag from
from the go
and
it's a mixed bag every step of the way
uh you could say oh gosh facebook is so
evil because they did that and the other
thing facebook is an absolute blessing
for most people most of the time
and that reality hasn't changed
you know there have some issues that are
still being sorted out and there are
quite consequential issues affect
presidential elections and things like
that
but they do get sorted out and i suppose
the optimism is that you bear down on
the problems
you don't solve them right away the
really tough problems do not get solved
right away climate is in that category
and and online behavior i think is in
that category there's lots of paradoxes
built into it you've got to sort your
way through them
um
gregory bateson and said he worked with
schizophrenics a lot he said that
you you'll see people who are as
schizophrenic as they ever were but they
sort of manage in the world
he said that's like learning to ride a
crazy horse
the problem with the horse is you
want it to go left and instead it
goes right and dumps you off and runs
away
but
you can figure out the situation of the
crazy crazy horse and people have these
neuroses
uh sometimes we talk therapy sometimes
with drugs sometimes just with life
figure out how to manage the damn thing
and ride the crazy horse and i think we
do that at the
social and civilizational and cultural
level as well
well i think this is the thing that you
point out in the book we have a few
questions along these lines as well is
that um kind of stewart also
knew when to leave
in some way or maybe
maybe
knowing is the right is the wrong term
but
got boring why did he always leave early
yeah there's
but there was this this restlessness and
and even sometimes you know these
failures like the education thing that
that then and somehow kind of launched
into the next thing so yeah what did you
learn in like watching those cycles well
i mean i think stewart explained it to
me as he had a relatively short
intention so you have a relatively short
attention span you would tend to get
bored and moved on move on that was
actually something that worked to your
advantage
yeah and you know the five year thing
that we talked about it's sort of a
project that is going somewhere takes
about five years to
mature
and
if you have a sort of a five-year
attention span which i guess i did
um
uh one point i wrote when when you can
do the thing you're doing in your sleep
wake up
go somewhere else
and and
things would get to that point where you
sort of can see what's coming and oya is
coming around again
and if invention is
what turns you on
uh
you're not getting it anymore from that
particular
domain and so you have to go somewhere
else yeah
and and there's
back when we had gears and gear shifts
uh
you had to go through neutral between
gears
that's kind of true and so there's a
period
um bob
uh would say that you know you're
somebody and then
you're nobody
and that you know when you call that
chapter anonymity i thought you were
referring to sort of a period when i was
nobody
and uh
it's important i think
that
and fuller really pointed this out
if you get addicted to being somebody
you will become a character of yourself
because you'll be you know picking up on
what people think you're famous for
um
and in order to
escape from that you have to give up on
being somebody
and be nobody of all but nobody is a
fantastic place to be it's it's like the
art student who's just out of school and
doesn't have a job
they're open to the world and that's
maybe the
hungry state foolish thing is to be
relish being a nobody
you know
i
i had to you know
the catalog is often seen in the framing
of the counter culture and the back to
land movement and i really wanted to
take it out of that framing and i think
my experience in working on this project
and telling people i was working on it
and the people from my generation i
can't tell you how many times i would
say i'm working on a book about the guy
who created the catalog and they got
you know that something that they saw i
ran into this over and over again
something they saw on the catalog
something they stumbled along in the
catalog stumbled upon the catalogue sent
their life in an orthogonal direction it
just happened too many times and i i
think kevin kelly has actually sort of
figured this out i mean the catalog
first of all information was scarce and
so the catalog was a centralized way to
to find new things in the world and and
to my mind you know
steve jobs called it uh google before
google but i don't think that's quite
right i i thought of it as a fantasy
amplifier and it would give people in in
kevin's words give people a way to
invent their own life and i it just
happened to my entire generation and it
was horizontal it wasn't limited to one
part of society i mean in the first
three years they told they sold three
million copies and you know where they
they were there in everybody's bathroom
or living room right all over the
country and they were each read by five
people and so it had a huge impact on on
that generation and actually that's a
great uh segway we have a question here
from the audience of how did you get the
source material for the first catalog
show again how did you get the source
material for the very first catalog oh
god it was so sketchy
there's a um
i discovered a thing called the single
copy order form
if you pretend you're a bookstore
you you can order
a single copy directly from a publisher
as i started ordering these books that i
wanted
uh
you know the discount and book
freaking and then you know
one out of five one out of ten would be
worth reviewing so there was actually
that problem
as you pointed out when we were doing in
the garage i was going through a lot of
books there were some that were so bad i
threw him in the wood-burning stove
he burned the book listen these books
were
worth burning
um
but it was that kind of thing and i
asked people i knew which wasn't that
many people
and they would put me under things like
cuisinart rods which were a way you
could teach math to kids and uh the
snuggly baby carrier and uh happy baby
food grinder and uh
just you know things that people knew
about that are actually pretty good
so i that first catalog was five dollars
it was what 64 pages the next one was
many of our pages and it was four
dollars and then we took the price down
and the pages up for until i lost my
mind
but you were brilliant at recruiting a
group of section editors who had
particular domain interests and you know
guys like lloyd kahn and jay baldwin
like we're coming to the end here but i
did want to talk a little bit about
what in a way what doesn't happen in the
book which is um the last kind of 20
years oh yeah or almost 30 years
and um
and you know actually the so there's the
biographical movie on stuart um that
some of you might have seen when we did
the early premiere here at the drive-in
movie theater during uh covid but i
think that they also stopped kind of at
the same place that you stopped and and
i think i'd love to hear a little bit
yeah and mikey decide where to stop with
this yeah how do you pick a you know a
guy who's still doing things and useful
things in the world how do you pick up
an endpoint and what i decided i mean i
wanted to separate i was trying to
separate biography from journalism and
to my mind um
both on the long now project which was
underway in which i did write a little
bit about and revive and restore were
two things that i couldn't assess i mean
in your case it's going to take 10 000
years or at least a couple of thousand
years how am i going to pass judgment on
it and revive and restore i think is a
similar thing and so it was a kind for
me it was kind of a neat moment
and um i you know i one of the things i
think stuart
i think felt a little bit uncomfortable
about in the book is he i end at this
meeting in berkeley where stewart
confronts the environmentalists
and um he said that
he felt they confronted me
that's fair but he went into the lion's
den
and um it's interesting that
my take on it and the the film's take on
it is different um i gave stewart the
last word because i thought he actually
had an interesting response to his old
friend peter coyote stood up and and
sort of went after stuart
and stewart responded cell phone came up
i think he was talking in the general
sense not you in particular but yes it
did come up
and anyway so it was a point in time
that i thought that i could end well i
just want to end this thank you first of
all i want to thank stuart for for being
so open to both the movie project and
your book project and laying his entire
life out in journals that's a brave
thing to do
and uh and for hiring me when i was 25
and and to go on this adventure with
and john for for writing this book if
this is so it's so amazingly important
to have this kind of stuff especially
when we are contemporaneous with someone
to ask like do all the interviews that
you did um and i think you know kevin
kelly i loved his comment comments he
now wants you to write a biography of
every single one of his friends
thank you very much
thank you
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]